um yo did you ever regret bringing all
the Wild and Out Boys into your beef
with Eminem No I thought that was
amazing you had you dragged all these
guys and now all these toxic Mountain
Dew drinking cargo short wear and Eminem
fans hey hey your attention is my
currency baby keep keep it going up all
of those guys are a lot more popular now
and than they were before they started
it and that was I mean that was all
again that was uh the media that was
just trying to get people to watch
wilding out you know what you shot a
music video for that oh we shot several
yeah Kevin we were on the set a while
and out but the logos was all in the
back do you think MGK beat Eminem in
their battle
what what it depends on beat I think I
think he won yeah I think I won I don't
agree with oh I don't I don't agree if
somebody picks a fight but doesn't show
up to the fight
I don't think he won
who so so who won how did he win by not
responding he did resp first of all I
responded to him he started talking [__]
first he was on fat Joe's record Talking
how many years ago see but that's the
thing everybody think I don't I love him
and him okay he start [__] with me
and then ran off like a little [__] so
you think because Eminem didn't reply to
your records he did not no he started he
started making records about what the
lady said on the Fat Joe record he did
like I don't know something like a lot
of [__] and I was like I went on I was
like why are you [__] with me like I
don't I know like it was some shitties
he said he's gonna cut my dick off or
some weird [__] like that like and I was
like huh like that was years ago so then
you replied so I was like oh let's have
some fun and I had a great [__] time
he got Shug on the record it was he was
lit I don't [__] get Suge Knight on a
song is this from jail yeah
just called in like [__] back in the
day when uh who was that rapper from
Sacramento x rated you never X-rated
no but I I think it was all for sport I
mean I love him I mean I love I mean
even so you think he won the battle
absolutely like we're talking for the
sport he didn't respond
I don't think he needed to he started it
see you wanted you wanted a mother
Mountain Dew [__] on Twitter
I'm not
energy drink do I want to know this guy
I did first of all I didn't I would love
it if I mean he he responded with a
tweet and all like because that became
the narrative because if you remember
how the narrative I smashed him over the
head people like oh [__] this [__] is
hot then I gotta look no absolutely I
smashed him over the head then I came
again and they were like that's when I
brought you know the black spot and all
the battle rappers and I'm like I just a
little too much they're beating their
now you guys are bullying him that was
the thing and then and then when I did
no that's what they said they said we
were bullying him he's like it's three
on one you had to go get battle rap
that's what I said yeah yeah see then
the third time I started bringing race
into it now that's why I went too far
then it just looked like I I was I did
too much I should have stopped at the
second record you should have put
Benzino on a song hey that was next
Everlast just pulled all his [__] but
we all know Eminem is the goat and like
he's one of them yeah he can yeah he's
definitely you know top five top five
yeah but I think Drake is coming for a
spot though like that's that's that I
mean there's an argument you made drinks
because it's All About Numbers Drake
might have passed Eminem
so then M might not have that fifth
Supply Eminem's a better rapper though
what is what is your definition of
better
I mean Eminem is a better word Smith
lyrics he's better oh I don't know about
Lyricist well I mean we've definitely
we've heard slower and Storyteller we
have heard Drake reference tracks
but see I don't want to get into that
because Drake is a better song maker
than the majority of the industry one
million percent Drake will wipe his ass
with Eminem as a song maker but if we're
talking about bar for bar
punchline and lyricism imma go with
Drake word play
even because only thing about because
WordPress difficult because wordplay has
to do with flow and Eminem is the king
of flow you think Drake barfer bar is
better than Eminem
we'll see that
like Eminem's a great Storyteller might
be one of my favorite storytellers in
hip-hop and that's I got him Cube biggie
Slick Rick storytelling and that to me
is probably the most difficult part of
hip-hop for sure uh pocket as well you
know Brenda's Got a Baby keep you at
home yeah
whole see I don't Hove is a great story
so Daisy has a song called Meet the
Parents it's on the blueprint too it's
one of the best storytelling records
ever oh no I mean just Streets is
Watching and it's that whole project but
if we're going the guys who can tell a
[__] story Eminem is probably number
one because ain't nobody topping Stan
ain't nobody topping rewind
he's good but he's not consistent with
this story it's not like assistant with
lyricism now but Nas did a whole story
backwards backwards I mean Nas did a
whole record as a bullet like like
creativity is out of here but if we're
talking storytellers Eminem is a better
Storyteller than Drake but if we're
going oh that bar for bar Eminem's never
said nothing bar wise that blew my mind
what is he said Hey listen I'm just
letting you talk mom spaghetti
spoken from a man who lost the battle
[__] you Cam
I did not lose and that's like hey you
might not have lost but you didn't win
yeah well I showed up to the fight
[__] you did show up like but I
know that's like you know I was just in
Detroit last week with my man Royce so
that's it's off no I mean listen that's
that's great but I think if we're
talking about the sport of it like to me
hip-hop is wrestling I think MGK won his
battle because I think the fact we even
questioned it yes he won I again I think
he had a better song yes and I think
like he was actually saying [__] that
people were like kind of thinking like
yeah this guy just wears [__] stupid
sweatpants he's been wearing the same
Jordan jumpsuit for 25 years but I think
I think
um
MGK made the same mistake that I made
that we were probably a little too
excited and too overzealous that we got
to battle with the leaned into it yeah
that we got to get in the ring with one
of the best to ever do it right I'm
dying off I was excited oh [__] he's
paying attention let's go but we're
gonna get so many while it out like
because the whole goal was to get
attention right I mean that's why
everyone's on social media don't give it
[__] up you all sold your souls
you got a [__] Instagram account
sold your soul to the devil on Instagram
uh but so we were and the real goal I
mean it was conversation that were being
had behind the scenes like we was trying
to get them at least to even just give
just to step foot on one just a little
in one of your minions send Royce no but
that's one first of all Royce is a goat
by himself one of the greatest leaders
hey there's an argument to me lyrically
Royce is just as good as Eminem I'm just
saying if not better damn it I said it
like like but uh and I mean I'm pretty
sure em would say the same thing that's
the reason why he invested in them and
made him his partner put his arm around
him but uh it's just you know it is what
it is like dude we know what it is we
know these marketing machines are are
massive yo you're kind of like
Switzerland in so many ways I feel like
you're cool with so many people have you
tried to ever like bring people together
that are having disagreements yeah all
the time but the best in the game to do
that is fat Joe fat Joe's the one that
got me and him to to I mean he wasn't
beefing but Fat Joe was like because one
it started over his record and then uh
and then he was like man come on y'all
was that on the Lean Back Remix
it was Joe's last album oh
yeah
that's what started all this [__] I was
on the station at Power and people like
you heard Eminem Disney I was like you
mean 20 years ago there's like no today
Lord above I think I heard it one time
and he brought up awesome oh [__] damn
Eminem can't let go man I want you think
he's just sitting at home watching
wilding out like [__] this morning
Seasons [__] this guy nah nah at this at
this point I think you know because what
was it all over Mariah right I get
that's where he started talking [__] and
then that's where you know again I
always never ever knew what the [__]
actually because he would bring up
Mariah so much in raps I was like that
was like what the [__] like yeah I think
it's it's a little bizarre yeah you know
he's a bizarre yeah shout out to bizarre
from D12 yeah yeah yeah
um they're gonna be coming at you [__]
you Kev
that's why your bootleg
they're going to be someone dissed me
that's what they'd say that's those guys
on Twitter
I see the comments all the time now I
know I call you [__] blackheads you
need to come up with nothing original